this is the first in a new series called
the theoretically speaking series
produced by the Simons Institute for the
theory of computing with sponsorship
from MSRI and Berkeley City College we
hope that there'll be several more in
the future we've had some talks in the
past that attempt to introduce a broad
audience to theoretical concepts about
computing we we had a speaker on the
famous P versus NP problem about a year
ago before that we had a meeting with
Alan Turing's biographer and we've had
other sessions sponsored with MSRI and
we hope to do have more of them in the
future and tonight we are very happy to
have Dan Bonet as our speaker Dan
received his PhD from Princeton in 1996
he's currently a professor at Stanford
where he holds the Rajeev Motwani chair
in computer science dan has taught three
massive online courses through the
Coursera platform courses on security
and cryptography he's received more
Awards than I can remember offhand so I
had to write them all down
Packard Sloan Terman RSA and griddled
prize most recently the very prestigious
Infosys foundation award he's an expert
on encryption and crypt analysis he is
known for innovations such as identity
based encryption and pairing based
encryption perhaps you'll learn
something about those during the talk
and the title of the talk is
cryptography from mathematical magic to
secure communication
Thank You dick for the kind of
introduction I'm really excited to be
here I love talks to the public I think
it's really important to expose the work
that's happening in theoretical computer
science to the public so thank you for
inviting me to give this presentation
everything I say here should be clear to
everyone and I'm really happy to see
some kids in the audience so if there's
anything I say that's not clear please
raise your hand and and ask a question
if it's not clear to you it's probably
not clear to to others as well so in
coming to speak here I was kind of
wanting what topic to present to you
there are lots and lots of stories in
crypto that I could I could talk about
it's an amazing field that's kind of at
the intersection of theory and practice
and so I chose one particular story that
I just love to tell and I hope you'll
enjoy it too so the story I want to tell
you about is a story about how something
that was developed really for no reason
other than intellectual curiosity and
how that thing has actually become
extremely practical and you are using it
today every time you use the Internet's
so that's what I'd like to tell you
about but our story actually begins a
long time ago our story begins actually
1800 years ago with a guy named D Afonso
so I'm sure many of you have heard of
him I've heard of him who lived on the
between 200 and 300 AD there's not a
whole lot actually did we know about the
youth on toast all we know is that he
lived in Alexandria and he wrote a bunch
of books that I'll talk about in just a
minute what he was interested in was
this question of what we call rational
points on curves
now why was he interested in this we
have no idea but he was interested in
this problem and so let me tell you a
little bit about what he did
but before I do that let me just explain
what I mean by rational point zone
curves so first of all I'm sure you all
know what a rational number is so like
1/2 13 over 8 are all rational numbers
basically the the ratio of two integers
is a rational number but for example
square root of 2 is not a rational
number and what is a rational point well
a rational point is a point XY where
both coordinates are rational now what
do I mean by rational points on curves
in fact kind of the first problem in his
book is one that he kind of just
presents and discounts very quickly is
he
asks the simple question of what are the
rational points in the equation x
squared plus y squared equals 1 now
probably many of you recognize this
equation this is just an equation for a
circle and the question he's asking is
basically what are the rational points
in the circle so there are very easy
rational and points that you can point
out in fact here are 4 of them
right basically the 0 1 1 0 minus 1 0
and 0 minus 1 but the question is are
there any other rational points on the
circle and I'm sure again was just a few
seconds of thought you'll see that for
example the point 4/5 3/5 is also a
rational point in the circle and in fact
you might recognize the Pythagorean
triangle Pythagorean triple there 3 4 5
and that's actually the reason why this
particular rational point is on the
circle and in fact he was just saying
very quickly that take any rational
number s so S is any rational number you
can map it to this point you can see
that if s is rational then these two
fractions are also going to be rational
numbers and that will actually give you
a point on the circle and in fact any
such any yes so in fact all points in
the circle all rational points in the
circle can be obtained in this
particular way yeah so just very simple
algebra will show you that for any
rational point this is in fact a point
on the circle these days this is not an
interesting observation to us because
all this says is that if you think of
the rationals as sort of a line then all
this says is that the set of rationals
on the line essentially map to the
circle so the circle in some sense is
kind of equivalent to a line as far as
rational points are concerned so that's
fine not interesting to us these days
even for him this was kind of trivial
but then he went ahead and generalized
and asked the question of a lot less
asked a similar question about lots of
other curves so here you have an ellipse
and a hyperbola and he was asking can we
find rational points on all those curves
and in fact he wrote lots and lots of
books on this question not just on this
question but on many other questions in
kind of basic algebra so he wrote the
famous 13 books of rhythmic arithmetic
ax these were stored in the Library of
Alexandria unfortunately only six of
them survived the story there is kind of
interesting in that you're part
the OL what happened to the Library of
Alexandria burned down well was burned
down destroyed and the fourth century AD
was basically destroyed or shut down and
many of the books that he wrote were
actually lost forever which is kind of
unfortunate I can almost imagine as it's
being destroyed people kind of just you
know pulling in the books the most
important books out of the library like
four of his books apparently made it to
the Vatican so someone just grabbed four
of his books put it on a boat and
shipped it over to the Vatican in the
Vatican Library interestingly it just
laid there for a thousand years until
someone finally turned in the 1500s
someone finally translated his books to
that to Latin though one of his books
made it to the famous four ma and that
was the birth of kind of what we now
call classical number theory so one way
to think about the destruction of the
knowledge of the Library of Alexandria
basically when the library was destroyed
all the knowledge of antiquity including
half of his books basically were lost so
one way to think about the destruction
of the Library of Alexandria is if it
hadn't been destroyed today we actually
might be a thousand years more advanced
than we really are yeah it actually
raises interesting questions about the
preservation of knowledge I hope this
will inspire some of you to think about
the preservation of the knowledge that
we generate especially the knowledge
that we generate we've generated in the
last 20 or 30 years most of it is stored
in digital form and if our civilization
happens to collapse most of it will be
destroyed as well so it's actually quite
an interesting question how do we
preserve the knowledge that we generate
and store in digital form you can see
the damage that's caused when knowledge
is is destroyed but anyhow going back to
our story when you look at these this
type of problems that the founders was
looking at today these are not
interesting problems we basically know
very general and very simple solutions
to these questions on of rational points
on ellipses rational points on a
hyperbola as all these are very very
simple questions to us they're just not
something that we're we're interested in
however however if you look all of a
sudden in one of its problems something
new pops up yeah one of his problems all
of a sudden in book number four problem
24 looks different from everything else
that he's done and what he's asking for
is basically can you find rational
points on this particular curve y
squared equals x cubed
SX plus nine now of course do you fine
just didn't say did it state it in this
in this language but when you translate
what the quote what the question that he
was asking it basically translates to
this exact question that I say here just
find rational points on this curve so
can someone suggest that can someone
point out some rational points on this
curve
give me one rational point on the curve
write one three excellent if you plug in
x equals one you get nine on the left
hand side and if you plug in y equals
three you also get nine so 1/3 is 1
example rational point in fact there are
a couple of other rational points like
this in fact there are six integral
points integral means that both
coordinates are integers so here I just
wrote the six simple integral points so
1 3 1 minus 3 0 3 0 minus 3 and so on
and the natural question that he asked
of course he knew of these six points
and acquired the natural question he
asks is what are the other other any
other rational points on this particular
curve how would we might how would we
might go about constructing other
rational points on this curve and so it
turns out this question actually is
quite deep yes and in fact today we tend
to generalize it to what's called an
elliptic curve ok so let me explain what
an elliptic curve is in fact what do you
fantasy very very special case of an
elliptic curve so what is an elliptic
curve a note the curve basically is
exactly the same equation that you found
just looked at y squared equals x cubed
but instead of having the constants be
fixed we let the constants a and B be
arbitrary yeah so a and B are going to
be some rational numbers and you know as
you can see basically do fantasies curve
I'm sorry so we let the the constants a
and B be arbitrary rational numbers
subject to some ridiculous sum some you
know technical constraints that I'm not
going to talk about too much here I'll
say that if this constraint is that is
violated so if this quantity happens to
be 0 again this degenerates to a non
interesting problem so we're only
looking at the case where this quantity
is not equal to 0 and in fact if you
look at you font assess curve of course
that's a special case where a is equal
to negative 1 and B is equal to 9 now
you can draw what this curve looks like
and is this bizarre kind of looking
shape that's what the curve looks like
and again you wonder why does he care
about finding it rational
points on this curve I have no idea yeah
why was the interest in this problem we
don't know he just happened to be
interested in this particular problem
when you think about this curve you
realize first of all a symmetric against
it across the x-axis because of because
Y is being squared in other word in
other words if XY is a solution then X
minus y is also going to be a solution
and that's why you get this nice
reflection across the x axis okay so
here we can even draw the the six
rational points that you already told me
right these were simple six rational
points and we were asking the question
it are there other rational points on
this curve before we go on I just want
to point out the name elliptic curves
has nothing to do or very little to do
with ellipses and in fact there's a very
nice article that I wrote down here
you're going to have the slide so you
can look up these references later if
you're interested there's a very nice
and accessible article called why
ellipses are not elliptic curves from
2012 that explains why these things are
actually not ellipses the name is
historic why it's called an ellipse I'm
not going to explain why it's called an
elliptic curve I'm not going to explain
here there's a very vague and distant
connection but these are not ellipses as
you can see this is not an ellipse and
it for a very deep reason as well okay
so so far so good so that's the problem
that he was interested in and what he
made was really kind of an amazing
observation think about this 1,800 years
ago he made the following observation so
here's the observation that he made he
said the falling so we have our elliptic
curve yes the particular curve that he
was interested in and he already knows
six points on this curve so here let me
draw two of the points P and Q and the
observation that he made is the
following well if we have two points on
this curve well what's the most natural
thing for us to do what do you do with
two points well if you have two points
you want to draw a line through them yes
so here let's splits let's draw a line
through them and the fact is that when
you draw a line through this curve it
must intersect the curve at one more
point with exactly one more point so why
does that happen so here it's going to
intersect the curve at one more point
are the reason the line has to intersect
the curve at three points is because of
this three here this is a cubic curve
degree three in a must intersect
therefore a line must intersect the
curve at three points okay so we get
this other point our
and then the observation that he made is
in fact that if P and Q are themselves
rational points
like the six points that we started with
it turns out the third intersection
point must also be rational and in fact
this is a very very easy fact to prove
you can take it as a homework exercise
if you like yeah it basically follows
from the fact that if you have a cubic
polynomial a rational cubic polynomial
that has two rational roots the third
root motto must also be rational very
simple fact ok so fine so now what does
this mean it means that if we have two
rational points we can build another
third rational points so this made him
very happy because now if you plug in
the points P and Q and you just solve
you know just do the algebra to figure
out what the point R is all of a sudden
this bizarre point pops up this integral
point 35 207 pops up says pops up as
well so we get another rational point
but now here's what we can do we know
that if R is a point in this curve then
minus R well sorry then reflecting the
point across the x-axis must also be a
point on the curve right because it's
symmetric across the x-axis we're going
to denote this point by minus R and now
we can do the same thing the same thing
again we can kind of draw a line through
the point P and minus R and what happens
now when we draw the point the line
through the point P and minus R we must
get another point where the where the
line intersects the curve so let me
denote this point by s so you see we get
a point s and lo and behold that must
also be a rational point by the same
argument right if P and minus R are
rational points s must also be a
rational point so we get another
rational point this one doesn't look as
pretty you say it's some crazy rational
number but it is a rational point that
we get fantastic and we can keep doing
this again and again and again right so
here we can take the point s reflect it
to get minus s and we can pass a line
through P and minus s and get yet
another rational point and we can keep
doing this over and over and over and
over and build lots and lots of rational
points and this made you found this very
happy we think yes so it's a way for him
to build lots and lots of rational
points by the way if any of you have
ever used PowerPoint you know that it's
extremely complicated to make these
animations so I'm going to make you
watch this one more time
given that I did all this work yeah so
here we have our points P and Q yeah we
draw a line we find the third
intersection points we draw a line we
reflect we draw another line and we get
another intersection point we reflect we
draw another line and we get another
intersection point and so on and so
forth so it's clear so given two
rational points this gives us a way to
build another rational point and by
iterating this we can build lots and
lots of rational points by the way
there's this nice book very very fun
book to read I really enjoyed reading
this book by Bosch Markova back in 1997
it's actually translation from Russian
that what she did is she actually went
through the you funguses work and
translated all of his ideas to two
modern mathematical language so this is
where this is how we kind of view his
work it's really quite impressive that
his ideas have kind of lasted lived and
lasted this long okay but now that we
would not exceed this this operation my
two points give us a third point you
kind of get a very natural sense of hey
maybe there's some sort of a addition
operation going on here right given two
points P and Q it kind of makes sense to
sort of define a sum of two points as in
some sense as the third intersection
point so in fact what we do is again
we're going to draw the line through the
points P and Q we're going to again have
our point R as the third intersection
point and we're going to come up with
this strange-looking definition as
saying that P plus it's a funny plus yes
not your natural point addition it's
this funny funny operation that I'm
going to denote by a plus with inside of
a box and in fact the way I'm going to
define it is as the sum of P and Q is
not going to be the point R but rather
the reflection of the point R across the
x-axis okay so we're going to say we're
going to say that actually P plus Q is
going to be minus the point R is that
clear so some two points take the two
points P and Q draw the line through
them and reflect and that will give us
the addition of that we're going to
define that as the sum of the points P
and Q that looks like a bizarre thing to
do why should we reflect and why are we
doing this intersection at all but it
turns out if you define it this way then
something magical happens the magic that
happens is we get the property of
addition which we call this
call associativity so what is the
sensitivity associativity means that
basically it doesn't matter what order
you do this addition in so you see P
plus Q doing that first and adding T is
the same as P plus Q plus T now if you
think about this this is totally bizarre
like why should this why should this be
true why why should possibly why should
you have this acitivity property let's
think for just one second about what
this means what it means is again if you
draw the lines through P and Q and you
look at the third intersection point and
you draw a line through that point and T
you're going to get exactly the same
point as if you drew a line through Q
and T you looked at that intersection
point and then you draw a line through P
yeah these are kind of completely
different operations you're doing these
two things should have nothing to do
with one another
and yet you get exactly the same point
at the end yeah and in fact you can do
ten pages of algebra to prove that this
is correct but in fact there are much
easier ways in more direct ways to see
that this is correct yeah so this has
been discovered it's going to discover
it again and again and again over the
ages until was finally at least in the
case of rational points this was finally
kind of solidified in a paper of Pangkor
a in the early 1900s
yeah so since since the order of
operations doesn't matter we can simply
write P plus Q plus T is everybody okay
with this so this gives us a funny way
to add points so we can add points on
this on this curve and build new points
from given points so far so good
any questions so far equals e ah
excellent excellent question Luca is
exactly right so if we have three
different but if we have two different
points it's pretty clear what P plus Q
is going to be but what do we do if we
have if we want to compute P plus P
there's no line to go through P that
goes through P and P right it's just one
point so what do we do in that case so
what do we do if we want to add the same
point to itself in other words we want
to compute well P plus P well the
solution is actually not that difficult
basically you can kind of think of the
two points P and Q is kind of converging
to each other
so kind of you're going to move them
closer closer and closer and closer to
one another all the time kind of running
the
the line that goes through them until
finally the points meet and if you
remember your high school math when the
two line when the two points meet the
line that goes to the curve is called
the tangent okay so we actually compute
the tangent at that point to the point P
and the tangent is going to intersect
the curve at another point which we call
our again we're going to reflect the
point R and that's what we're going to
define as P plus P so far so good so
that's how we can actually double point
so we can compute P plus Q when P and Q
are different we can compute P plus P
when P are when when the two points are
the same and because and again because
of associativity now we can write 2 P 3
P 4 P we don't have to worry about the
order of operations we don't have to put
parentheses around these additions
because of this associativity property
so we have a very nice sequence of
points here 2 P 3 P 4 P 5 P 6 P and so
on and so forth and so again this is
this is a really nice way to build new
rational points from just one point P so
if I have one point on the curve I can
compute P plus P then P plus P plus P P
plus P plus P plus P and so on and so
forth and every time you know there's a
chance that I'll get a new rational
point and in fact on the on the curve
that I showed you the fantasy's curve
will actually end up getting infinitely
many points like this ok so that's how
we double points there's one last corner
case let's see if anyone can see there's
one last corner case when we run into
trouble
yes exactly
excellent I was waiting for that
excellent excellent ah actually hold on
I have some fancy animations to show you
first so here we can take the points P
and R and we get to P now we can we can
pass a line through the point P and to P
we get another point we reflect that
we're going to get the point three P and
we can continue computing this way and
get 4 P 5 P so it gives us an algorithm
a very simple algorithm to generate more
rational points on the curve now the
last corner case I have to worry about
is what do we do if we have P and minus
P the line through P n minus P doesn't
really intersect the curve anywhere else
yeah I mean it only intersects the curve
at those two points and nowhere else so
I kind of lied to you
when I said that every line must
intersect the curve at three points in
fact here's a line the only
intersect the curves at two points two
points so what do we do well what we do
is we sort of cheat but there's a formal
justification for why we cheat what
we're going to do is we're going to
introduce one more kind of artificial
points which we'll call the point in
infinity and we'll say this funny curve
intersects the intersects the curve at
infinity and we'll call this special
point O and that makes our that that's
the last point that we have on the curve
okay so we can define P plus minus P to
be O and in fact P plus O therefore
would be P so o is like zero that's why
we use o to denote it and now we're all
happy now we have a complete way to kind
of add two points and so we have a nice
addition rule so just to summarize
everything I've said so far just this is
a quick summary so we have our curve we
have two points P and Q we can add two
points so given P and Q we can compute
the point P funny addition Q using the
following rules so first of all if P is
negative Q yeah if E is equal to
negative Q then the sum is just this
point at infinity this zero point if we
want to double so if P is equal to Q the
doubling rule is you compute the slope
of the tangent just again this just
happens to be the slope of the line
that's tangent at the point P and you
just plug the number the values into
this formula and you get the point R
yeah so you get X R and Y are together
they make up the point R so far so good
so that's how we get our our our sum of
two point of a points or doubling of a
point if the if we just want to double a
point and if we want to add two points
then you know again we compute the slope
of the line that goes through P and Q
and that gives us the third point that
gives us the third point R I just wanted
you to see that there are kind of
explicit formulas that we can use
they're very easy to compute very
efficient you can see all we're doing is
just computing some squares and
divisions another square they're very
efficient to compute so I guess point
doubling is two squarings and one
division in a couple of addition so very
efficient very fast operations so now
that we understand this idea let's go
back to do fantasies curve so here we
have our curve X cube minus X plus 9 and
here we have the point 1 and minus minus
3
we started with the points 2p if we
double the point yeah if we just compute
P plus P again Wiens we pass a line
through P we look at the intersection
point and we reflect we get this funny
point what will be denoted by 2p and in
fact this is what the Afon test did yeah
so the afonso is kind of got the point
2p and that's where he stopped he didn't
he was happy that he got one more
rational point and that nothing else
interested him this was kind of a
problem with his approach he never kind
of asked for a complete answer he just
wanted one solution and that's all he
cared about fine but we can continue
right we can continue and compute the
point 3p and 4p and you see these points
kind of get uglier and uglier and uglier
as we as we go along but again we have
an algorithm here that produces lots and
lots of new rational points on this
curve so what's the next question so now
we have all these rational points on the
curve what's the most natural question
to ask now where's what can you get as
close as you want to anyone's ah well
actually that's a good question but the
one I had in mind is yes thank you is
are these all the rational points on the
curve are we getting all the points that
are on the curve this way yeah very
natural question and it turns out the
answer is no in fact if we look at the
point Q which is 0-3 one of the integer
points that we had before we're never
going to get that point as a multiple of
the point P ok so we can take the point
Q zero three now we can generate more
points right so two Q 3 Q 4 Q by the way
is kind of bizarre the point 3 Q gives
you all the sudden this funny integer
point yeah this kind of pops out of
nowhere like this bizarre why why do
these integers have to sit on this curve
but again turns out there's deeper
reasons for everything there's a good
reason why why they're on this curve but
yeah so this gives us a way to generate
more more more points but now that we
have these points P and Q we can look at
even combinations of them right so we
can do P minus Q 2 P plus Q P plus 2 Q
yeah we can start combining them to form
more and more and more curves more and
more points and now the question is are
these all the rational points on the
curve right can you generate like all
points on the curve rational points as
linear combinations of P and Q so in
fact this is true yes there's a rash
there's a theorem that says that in fact
all the rational points on do fantasy's
curve can be obtained basically by take
integer combinations of P and Q okay so
again I want to make sure it's clear
what I mean by integer combinations here
you take the point P you do this funny
doubling to multiply it by you by some
integer you you take the point Q you do
doubling to multiply it by the integer V
you sum up the two points and that gives
you another point on the curve okay and
if you do this for all integers U and V
you basically get all the points points
on this curve and again there's a paper
by from 2002 that analyzes this
particular curve and in fact it shows
that these are all the rational points
on this curve so the fact that we can
generate all rational points by two
points P and Q means that the rank of
the curve that when we say that the rank
of this curve is - yeah it takes two
points to generate all rational points
now there are all sorts of interesting
computational problems I come up yeah so
this kind of now boils down this leads
directly to a computer science question
which is well if I give you an equation
for an elliptic curve I give you the a
and B that define an elliptic curve can
you compute its rank efficiently yeah is
there an algorithm to do it turns out
that's actually quite a difficult
problem
yeah computing it exactly however
there's a well there's a beautiful oak
conjecture in mathematics called the the
birds one or two dire conjecture the BSD
conjecture
that if it happens to be true this is
actually one of the deepest problems in
in well in mathematics and all the
geometry in particular if it turns out
to be true then we get actually an
algorithm that pretty much gives us more
or less actually gives us the actual
rank of a curve yeah so you can see how
the deepest problems in mathematics
really are just computer science
problems yeah it gives us an algorithm -
we're looking for an algorithm to
compute ranks and we need this we have
an algorithm can't we have a candidate
algorithm except we can't prove that it
works if you could prove that it works
you will get a million dollars from the
Clay Institute's
because that's actually one of the
millennium problems that's considered
one of the deep problems of mathematics
yeah so we also know for example that
the rank of every yeah so we know that
the rank of every curve is finite so the
question is you know can it be is there
a bound on the rank again can we compute
the rank
and so on and so forth okay so they're
very I guess another problem is given a
curve can you actually come up with an
algorithm to find rational points on
this curve that turns out if the bsd
conjecture is true we actually have also
have a decent algorithm for coming up
with rational points on these curves so
again these deep problems in mathematics
really are just computer science theory
problems yes so this deep connections
there okay so the last thing I want to
tell you before we switch over to crypto
is that in fact when you study these
questions of rational points on these
curves actually the correct way to do it
is order a rather there's a lot of
information to be gained by looking at
actually curves modulo primes
okay so instead of looking at the curve
over the rationals let's actually ask
how many solutions or what are the
solutions or what are the points on this
curve actually modulo a particular prime
P say ok so here we have so let's say
that FP is the set of numbers 0 to P
minus 1 in fact here I'm going to be a
little imprecise and I'm going to
literally think of FP as a set of
integers 0 to P minus 1 and I'm asking
what is the set of points XY in FP you
know pairs in FP x FP that satisfies
this equation
ok so we're asking for solutions now
modulo the prime P and again let's look
at your fantasies curve so let's say we
look at your fantasies curve mod 7 and
so we have our integral points of course
if we have an integer point that's also
an integer point mod 7 but all of a
sudden another point pops up yes person
right over
so it's wondering if
you will talk about finding the inverse
and you would be like if there's some I
lost vision of finding the universe or
laughing on the curve to find work well
given given a P you can easily build -
be just by reflecting given to P you can
easily build - to be just by reflecting
oh that's a good question so like could
you have so like 1 over U is not an
integer is that what what does it mean
here yeah no no no no this is a good
this is a good question like you asking
me like what is half P what is 1/3 P
what is 1/4 be yeah okay so it's a good
question but actually not one that would
take a little while to answer so I'm
actually not going to answer it now come
see me after the after the lecture yes
there's a good answer I mean ok I'm not
going to answer that now ok all right so
we have our curves so that so we were
looking at curves modules these Prime's
for example we can look at your
fantasies curve modulo 7 so we have our
integral points of course if it's a
solution over the integers it's going to
be a solution modulo 7 but all of a
sudden a new point pops up yeah there's
this point to minus 1 to plus minus 1 so
2 1 + 2 minus 1 that pops up and you can
very easily see that in fact if we plug
in y equals 1 and x equals 2 yes so we
plug in the point into the fantasy's
curve you see that when we evaluate well
you see them when we value it basically
we see that we get that actually 1 is
equal to 15 modulo 7 both of these are
actually 1 modulo 7 so therefore the
point 2 1 really is a point on this
curve modulo 7 so on this particular
curve modulo 7 you see if you just count
you'll see there are nine points right
there's the point in infinity and then
there's these four other points on the
in the in the basically in an FB cross
FB okay so there are nine points on this
curve yeah and now we can do then an
interesting thing about this is now we
can apply that our funny you know
addition formulas new addition rules
actually modulo 7 so if I take two
points I can add them up modulo 7 and I
get another point so here for example
these two integral points
if I add them up I get a new point two
one so we get a nice addition rule on
nine points and that gives us actually a
way well you know it's a nice addition
rule that we can use and remember we
have this associativity property that
the order of addition doesn't really
matter okay so the next question is well
how many points are there on this curve
modulo P and it turns out there's a
beautiful beautiful result this is
actually one of the most wonderful
results in this space that actually
shows gives you actually a really good
bound on the number of points modulo P
I'm not going to be very explicit about
this I'll just say that the number of
points on the curve modulo P is not P
but it's very close to P yeah so it's a
most like two square root of P away from
from the prime P so the number of points
is very very close to P just remember
that because it'll become important in a
minute and the amazing thing is actually
this result that's due to Jose and V
actually not only does it give you a
bound the number of points but in fact
it gives you efficient algorithms to
compute the number of points on the
curve yeah this is an amazing fact that
it doesn't matter how big P is B could
be an enormous Liebig number you can
still count the number of points on this
curve in in time that's only polynomial
in the logarithm of P ya and this you
get you can only do this if you have a
really good understanding of what these
points are and that's exactly what this
theorem gives you kind of gives you a
lot of information about how the points
behave and that gives you an algorithm
to actually count the number of points
on these curves okay so this will become
important in just a minute
okay so this is like the quick overview
of do fantasies work yes so and again
what I wanted to tell you is first of
all all this beautiful theory developed
essentially for no reason right nobody
really needs rational points on curves
yeah so why why why I mean there's a lot
of work that went into this it's
beautiful beautiful work lots of
intellectual curiosity but there was no
reason no no like no application for why
this stuff is needed so you should be
asking you're probably wondering like
why am I telling you all this like what
does it have to do with secure
communication and it turns out this
beautiful theory that was developed
turns out to be immensely immensely
useful you're using this now every day
when you browse the web every day it's
really quite remarkable how something
that had basically was developed just
for intellectual curiosity has actually
taken over the world
and so let me show you why so now we're
gonna switch gears and talk about modern
crypto and let's see what actually how
this thing is actually useful okay so uh
you know in crypto basically there is
the classical part of crypto which says
imagine I might I have my browser and
I'm trying to connect to my bank well
let's imagine that my browser in my bank
actually already have a shared key so
there's a key that might that my browser
know knows and a key that my bank knows
and nobody else knows what this key is
well in that case it turns out we
already know how to communicate securely
how to send secure messages from one to
the other there's a particular mode I
imagine many of you know it's called AES
GCM that allows us to send messages in
such a way that even if an eavesdropper
listens to the conversation I'm going to
call the eavesdropper Nancy because
that's the closest name I can think of
to some three-letter agency so even if
Nancy used drops on the conversation
she's not going to be able to figure out
what uh what is being transmitted okay
interestingly it's you know you think
this is like the most basic problem in
crypto right the two sides share a key
they want to send messages to one
another interestingly it's only in like
2005 that we learned how to do this
correctly even now there are debates on
whether that's correct and there's even
something called the Caesar competition
which is looking for the next round next
way of encrypting when the two sides
share a secret key like even the the
most basic problem this is this is like
crypto 101 even the most basic problem
in crypto is still something that's
still an active area of research and
things are going to be changing over the
years but today when you encrypt you
will use this GCM mode there's a lot of
support for it and that's most what
mostly what your browser does okay but
now that you see this the obvious
question is where did this shared key
between Alice and her bank come from
where did it actually come from and so
the solution to that actually is due to
a very famous trio diffie-hellman and
Merkel working many years ago at
Stanford actually here's a picture of
them from there from the old ages old
age when they when they did this work
and
up with this beautiful idea again I
imagine many of you know this this idea
so let me kind of go through it somewhat
quickly so they came up with this
beautiful idea for generating a shared
key between Alice's laptop and her bank
and the idea is as follows basically
you're going to fix a prime some prime P
and an element and some number G between
1 and P fix that those two numbers and
now what Alice will do is she's going to
choose some random integer a in the
range 1 to P minus 1 she's going to send
over G to the a to the bank yeah so she
just sends that in the clear and then
the big that's exactly the same thing
picks a random B and sends over G to the
B over to Alice now what Alison bought
what Alice the bank will do is well they
can generate their shared key as follows
basically
the Alice what she does is she takes the
value that she got from the bank raises
it to the power of her random a and you
notice by rules of exponentiation B to
the a is just G to the B to the a which
is G to the a B yeah so that that's the
value that she gets and the bank does
exactly the same thing and lo and behold
they get actually the same value ok so
just again rules of exponentiation if
you just remember your basic rules of
exponentiation that b times a is equal
to a times b and that guarantees that
both of them get the same the same value
this is a very basic protocol and from
this view to the AP you can actually
generate a shared secret between the two
the two sides so the first question you
should ask me is why is this secure yeah
clearly it works but the question is why
why is this secure and so the security
of this protocol actually depends on the
following problem yeah so we're getting
to the punchline in just a minute yet so
we have our our public values P and G
you notice that the adversary when he is
so Nancy yes when she eavesdrops on this
on this channel what she gets to see is
again the public values P and G she gets
to see the public values of the
participants send this a and B and what
you would like to compute is the secret
that they're going to compute that
they're going to jointly compute so what
you'd like to compute is just due to the
a B value so far so good that's what
you'd like to do this problem is an
extremely famous problem in crypto it's
called so famous that
it has a name it's called the
computational diffie-hellman problem or
CDH for short so I'm going to refer to
this as C GD H from now on basically the
problem is given G to the a and G to the
B can you compute G to the a B okay so
the question we're asking really the
security of this method depends on how
hard is this
CDH problem yeah so how hard is the CDH
problem modulo P well unfortunately this
problem is not as hard by the way this
is the only field that you can think of
well the only feel that that that we
know of we're a fast algorithm is
actually a huge problem yeah usually we
want fast algorithms here fast
algorithms are real a real problem yeah
so the question we're asking is how hard
is the CDH problem on P and it turns out
there are beautiful beautiful algorithms
quite deep and you know about 20 years
old that show that this problem is not
as hard as you'd like yeah so if you
have an N digit prime there's an
algorithm that solves this problem in
exponential time but the exponent is the
cube root of n cube root of n this is
much much faster than an exponential
time algorithm which would be 2 to the N
yes
so basically what I'm saying is that the
CDH problem there is a relatively
efficient algorithm even though it is
exponential the exponent is not as big
as we'd like it to be and as a result
the world record and computing install
in breaking the CDH problem actually
allows you to do it for a hundred and
eighty digit prime yeah this is kind of
mind-boggling that we can do it so the
number is 2 to the 8 to 10 to the 180
yeah 180 digit prime 10 to the 180
scanning through all possible possible
solutions kind of breaking it by brute
force would take more time than you know
the age of the universe squared and yet
we can do it we can do it and it only
only takes 50 years 50 54 years which
means with 50 computers you can do it in
one year for example so yeah
unfortunately this problem is just not
that hard somebody had a question oh why
Sheriff I
yeah so think of it at time think of it
as cycles on the computer yeah just very
simple yeah x86 cycles to become to be
to be concrete other questions yeah
similarly what did you mean by random
random random 8 oh no no no you cannot
buy one on Amazon you have to generate
it yourself yeah you have to have yeah
how to generate randomness is a whole
other talk which I'll be happy that's
another crypto story but that's a story
for a different day how to generate
randomness on a computer big problems
there but let's assume that's already we
already know how to how to do that any
other questions ok we're getting to the
interesting parts ok so fine so yeah so
this problem unfortunately is not very
not very hard and as a result if we want
it if we want it to be difficult for
Nancy to solve this problem in practice
what we end up doing is we end up using
really really big primes like 600 and
717 digit Prime's ok so because the
primes are this big basically they're
2048 bits because the primes are this
big basically that means that that
famous protocol this de jamón famous
protocol is relatively expensive
relatively slow yeah we have to do
computations modulo very very large
numbers and that's not good for
performance so think about Google on
their servers they have to constantly be
doing these exponentiations modulo these
617 digit primes and unfortunately
that's just expensive to do yeah how did
I know it was prime excellent question
ok so a whole other story I could have
told you I could have talked about is
how do we test if a number is prime or
not that is actually a very very long
and fascinating story but again we have
good ways to test it a number is prime
in fact we even have ways to do it
provably but that's a story for another
day so today let's assume that we have
ways to tell that a number actually is
prime yeah
excellent question ok so that's
basically where things were and that
actually is unfortunately quite sad
because again this means that key
exchange is expensive which means Google
has to buy many more machines to satisfy
the world's needs ok
so what happened so what happened I mean
the amazing thing is the question is can
we use so what happens when we run this
protocol using the funny group that the
you fountas was interested in right so
do you find this as work all of us at
1800 years ago well at least a modern
version of it all of a sudden starts to
apply to this key exchange problem so
the question is what happens if we run
the exact same protocol except instead
of doing multiplication modulo P we do
this funny thing with lines through
curves and that's that's going to be our
definition of multiplication so we're
going to fix the prime P we're going to
fix a curve modulo P and we're going to
fix a point P on this curve and what
Alice and her bank will do is exactly
the same thing as before Alice will
choose some random number u now instead
of sending G to the U she's going to
send u times the point P and by now you
guys are all experts and what does it
mean to multiply a point by an integer
on the curve yeah so you know what 2 P 3
P 4 P 5 P you know what that is now here
what I'm telling you is let's multiply
it by some rep by some number you that
only Alice knows ok so Alice will send
you times P Bob will do exactly the same
thing he'll send V times P and the
secret key is going to be exactly what
they did before exactly the same
diffie-hellman protocol except now dawn
on these points on these curves okay so
Alice will take the value she got from
Bob multiplied but from the bank
multiplied by you and you can see you
get u V times P and Alice and the bank
will do exactly the same thing and again
they get exactly the same point the
reason they get the same point is
because of the associativity property
yeah the magical associativity property
I told you about guarantees that both of
them actually get the same value yes so
again we get this quote this we get this
protocol that works exactly as before
but now on elliptic curves this idea by
the way I should say is due to Co blitz
a victor Miller and commercialized by
Scott Vanstone and what's the question
that you need to ask clearly the
protocol works the question is how
secure is this method yeah how hard is
this method to break so our friend Nancy
how long would it take take her to break
this this CDH problem so how hard is the
CD
problem on the curve again what you
would need to do is given the point P
the point u P and the point V P she
would need to compute the point u times
V P okay so the question is how hard is
this to do and here magically yeah this
this group here actually that's sorry
this this addition rule here has so
little structure or let's say far less
structure than working modulo primes
that in fact the best known algorithm
now is much much worse than it is
working modulo primes okay so in fact
the best don't outgrow algorithm now is
basically exponential whereas before you
notice this this cube root of n that was
causing trouble before disappeared now
the best known algorithm for breaking
CDH basically is an exponential time
algorithm so the problem is much harder
the fact that it's harder means that we
can actually use smaller Prime's in our
protocol and still have the protocol be
secure in fact I'll tell you in practice
what sorry I should say the world record
for computing CDH modulo on these curves
is actually a 34 digit number 34
remember for when we were working mod P
the world record was 180 digits for
elliptic curve the world record is only
34 digits the problem is so hard that we
can't do anything beyond 34 digits yes
and in fact in practice what's being
used is just a 77 digit prime not 600
digits like before but only 77 digits
because the prime is so much shorter and
yet the problem is as hard as working
modulo P yes with the with it with the
simple with a simple multiplication we
can't we so again the prime is so much
shorter that the algorithm actually runs
much much much faster around ten times
faster than if we just did simple mod P
operations so far so good so because the
problem is harder we can get everything
to run faster fantastic so so this is
good yes question so to compute you P
from P
so she has to compute u times P from P
why is that easier than computing UV
from VP well Alice can do that the
question is whether the weather Nancy
the East dropper whether she can do that
she doesn't have you and she doesn't
have V yeah it's an excellent excellent
question she doesn't have you and she
doesn't have V and yes he's supposed to
compute UV times P yeah so that's the
problem that's the thing that we believe
is hard and in fact because this is so
much faster like I said this is ten
times faster than just working modulo
primes this thing is literally taking
over the world and so every time you
guys connect to Google what's actually
being done if you look down here you'll
see that your secure connection to
Google actually uses what's called a lip
to curve diffie-hellman yeah so every
day every day when you connect to Google
you're actually you should be thanking
diya phantos for his work because that's
exactly 1,800 years ago that led
directly to this method to me this is a
unbelievable story of something that was
just developed for complete intellectual
curiosity all of a sudden is something
that the whole earth is using on a daily
basis all the time if you're a fan of
Bitcoin these curves are also used in
Bitcoin - Vera - ensure that money is
not being spent incorrectly so these
curves are basically taking over the
world and slowly the whole the whole
world of implementing crypto is moving
to implementing them in this particular
way now here comes the troubling part
the troubling part the question is we
know that these curves are good for
crypto because you know they make things
faster the question is what curve should
we actually use
well so what curve should be you so what
happened here is basically the
government's that stepped in and said
here's the curve you know government to
the rescue and here is the curve that
you should all be using now you know to
joke about you know I'm here for the
government and I'm here to help you yes
how do you know when someone is lying
well now I'm kidding I don't we don't
know if they were actually trying to do
the right thing but let me tell you the
story
I'm kidding actually they were trying to
do the right thing but the National
Institute of Standards basically
standardized one well a small set of
curves but there's one curve
if that's basically taken over the world
this curve is called p2 five six because
of its parameters the curve is defined
by this equation here where the value B
is literally specified in the standard
you can see what B is here's the prime
that they standardized so this is a
curved modulo this Prime here's the
number of points on this curve it's this
crazy number over here and here's the
point P that's on this curve this is the
point that you're supposed to use when
you do the key exchange okay so the
National Institute of Standards actually
tells you which curve you're supposed to
be doing and that's the one that most
websites use so again if you had told
you phantos that his work is going to be
standardized by the government I think
he would be somewhat surprised yes yes
excellent question we're going to get to
that in just one second so just to kind
of finish the point here basically we
did a survey of different websites of
the something like 60% of all web sites
you know the popular websites support
the Lipton curve key exchange and like
96% of them use this one particular
curve one particular curve yes so it's
natural to ask where does this curve
come from where does it come from
well you open up the standard and here's
what it says in the standard it says
there's a particular seed literally
there's a seed that's written in the
standard if you compute the sha-1 hash
of this of this magical value that's in
the standard basically it gives you the
parameters for the curve so the value B
that the value P and the value B does
define the curve basically come from
this from this seed so the question now
is well where the de-seed come from and
the answer is we have no idea yeah it's
literally written in the standard and we
have no idea how it was generated there
are some claims as to how it was
generated but we have no way to verify
it so the problem now is well well so we
have this one curve generator magically
and the question is you know how hard is
the CDH problem on this one particular
curve we know that there are some curves
where the CDH problem is easy how do we
know that this curve is not one of those
curves that's we don't that's the answer
question yes
I apologize this asinine but why is the
see patch what does that create well the
series has two basic basically to give
you some confidence in that it wasn't
chosen totally adversarially so that
there's some munging and crunching that
went into it
so that presumably this curve was
generated you know not you know with
some some with without giving complete
control of what the parameters are yeah
that's that's a simple answer yes yeah
it's broken as a cryptographic hash but
that's not relevant to the to this to
this to this discussion yeah so good
it's a good point yeah so Nancy that's
exactly the question that is exactly the
question was did Nancy have any input as
to what the seed is supposed to be and
the answer is we don't know yeah imagine
so the the situation that we're all
fearful of is imagine one in a million
curves happen to have an easy CDH
problem yes one of the million curves
what that would mean is you would have
to cycle through a million random seeds
until you find one that you can break
and that's the one that you publish in
the standard that's what everybody's
fearful of this has international
consequences yes so the Chinese are kind
of worried about using this curve the
Russians are worried about using this
curve this is quite remarkable the
impact international impact this
basically causes an international
incident yeah I think that's the first
time that math causes international
incidents yeah so it's quite remarkable
what's happening here in fact because of
this the National listed with standards
has actually decided to backpedal away
from this curve and next month they're
actually running a workshop on
discussing how to how to generate better
curves this is a very very active area
of research how should we generate
curves the deep question here what we
would love to have is basically one
curve that is as hard as all other
curves in other words if you can break
the CDH problem on this one curve that
would mean that you can break CDH on all
curves so if there's some curve that's
hard
this one curve must also be hard that's
what we would like to have but
unfortunately we don't know how to do
that yes
ah the question when I say hard I mean
is the CDH problem does it take
exponential time to solve so a curve is
hard if CDH takes exponential time to
solves that's the problem
we don't know we don't know yeah this is
actually one of the most embarrassing
problems of computer science right it's
been the field is 50 years old and yet
we can't prove that anything is hard yes
that's the city that's the state we have
to live in and yet we have to do
practical crypto and so we have to
assume that certain problems are hard
and the question is what problems do we
assume are hard well we'd like to have
problems that are as hard as possible in
the sense that if they're broken
then a huge collection of problems is
also broken so we'd like to have one
curve that if this curve is broken all
other curves models must also be broken
but that we don't know how to do there
are other construction crypto that
actually do have this property but
curves do not have this property so
that's that's where the debate is
basically how do we generate this curves
these curves it's a very active area of
research now obviously these days you
can't talk about crypto without
mentioning Nancy more explicitly and so
what is it what does the NSA say about
this problem well so they have on their
website they actually make a very strong
case for using these elliptic curves in
particular they kind of say if you want
this level of security they go through a
very rigorous analysis to say this it'll
be basically you'll have a 10x
performance increase yes
10x very enticing and this is why the
world is actually moving to these curves
now on the bottom they say basically
elliptic curve cryptography provides
greater security and more efficient
performance than the first generation
public key techniques as vendors look to
upgrade their systems they should
seriously consider the elliptic curve
alternative for computational and
bandwidth advantages now here's the
frustrating thing about doing crypto in
the real world these days as you know
the NSA has two parts right they're in
charge both of defensive and offensive
technologies the problem is we have no
idea which part of the NSA is actually
sending us this message yes this is
what's what's frustrating but that's the
world we live in I guess that's what
makes crypto interesting that's kind of
the policy debates that goes goes on
yeah well it's done by choice basically
so developers at these websites they
choose to use the the NIST curve because
that's what is typically implemented in
most cryptographic libraries yeah there
are other curves that are being debated
today what's implemented is the NIST
curves it's going to be many many years
before implementations are changed to
move away from the NIST curve so we're
kind of stuck with them for quite a
while but at least you know where the
debate is starting as to what new curves
we should be using to me and the reason
I wanted to tell you the story to me
this is incredible
that this deep math that was developed
is causing such a crisis on an
international level it's really quite a
remarkable story ok so with that I'm
going to move I'm going to skip this and
I'm going to move over to two more
recent work in crypto and so let me
conclude with with one last topic in the
remaining few minutes I have I'll stop
in five minutes or so which is to say
well what if the computational
diffie-hellman problem was really really
easy yeah so imagine imagine we had a
curve that has the following bizarre
property imagine the curve had the
property that given you P and VP it's
actually easy to compute you VP so in
other words the CVH problem is just
trivial on this curve however the
following a slightly different problem
still was hard namely just given U times
P it's difficult to recover you okay
this problem has a name it's called a
discrete log problem so imagine that CDH
was actually easy but this problem over
here was actually hard this would be a
disaster for key exchange the
diffie-hellman protocol would be broken
because the attacker given you P and V P
he can actually compute the secret key
between Alice and a bank but the turns
out if we had such a structure it would
be an enormous benefit for crypto
there's tons and tons of application
that we can do and let me show you why
this would be such an interesting it's
kind of a bizarre construct right but
all of a sudden you can solve CDH but
there's this other problem that's still
difficult why is it such a useful why
would it be so useful for crypto
well you can sort of a think of a funny
encryption mechanism where the way I
encrypt the message m is the the
ciphertext is literally M times the
point P okay so the encryption of a
message M is M times P now this
encryption scheme because CDH is easy
has a couple of remarkable properties
yeah in particular if I give you two
cipher texts I give um one P and M two P
these are two this is an encryption of
m1 and this is an encryption of m2
if you think about it if you add these
two cipher text together add in the
sense of adding points on curves you get
m1 plus m2 times P and because CDH is
easy you can compute m1 times m2 times P
yeah so basically what you're doing here
is you're able to compute on ciphertext
right you're able to add the plaintext
and you're able to multiply the
plaintext without knowing what the
plaintext are just given the encryption
encryption of those plaintext now if you
can do addition or multiplication you
can do any function you want okay so
just given the encryption of a
particular message you can compute the
encryption of a function of that message
so this is what's called computations on
a ciphertext it also goes by the name of
fully homomorphic encryption if you've
heard of it and in fact this exact
structure if we had such a construct if
we had such an algebraic structure where
CDH was easy but the screed log was hard
we could actually build very secure very
simple fully homomorphic encryption
schemes and in fact this would be
fantastic I mean this type of contract
would have lots and lots and lots of
other applications
okay so unfortunately this is an open
problem we don't know how to build this
today we don't know how to build this
but who knows maybe one of you will come
up with with a solution to this so yeah
I'd like to pose this as an open problem
we have some evidence that maybe this is
not possible but it's not conclusive
evidence there's still definitely hope
that this can be done so I hope the
process of problem clear when you go
home tonight I hope you will think a
little bit yeah can you actually
construct some sort of algebraic
structure that has these that has these
properties yeah so CDH is easy but
discrete log is hard so since we really
we'd really like to have this we'd
really like to be able to do
computations on ciphertext but we can't
do it using
this particular trick then what can we
do well it turns out that elliptic
curves actually have one they have an
additional incredible structure that
allows us to sort of emulate this CDH
CDA easy CDH problem but only one time
so it only allows us to do one one-time
CDH yeah and this is what this is the
beginning of a huge area called a
parrying based crypto which
unfortunately I think I'm only going to
be able to outline at a very high level
so I'll just give you the history here
so this the idea of pairing based crypto
actually dates back all the way to and
reveille we've already seen various work
yeah earlier in the lecture dates back
to 1949 this is by the way when you so
as part of his work unbounding the
number of points on curves he developed
this pairing and that's the thing that's
now become so useful in crypto I have to
tell you a story here in that Andre
wrote a beautiful by autobiography of
his life reading that autobiography
basically shows you you know the chaos
that happened in Europe during World War
two and how it affected mathematicians
it's actually quite a nice book to read
in it he says at some point during the
war he actually spent some time in jail
because he was a conscientious objector
and he says that his time in jail was
basically the most productive time of
his life this work he did while he was
in jail apparently they were required to
give him paper and pencil and that's all
he needed to the point where he was
going to write a letter to the head of
the French mathematics academy saying
that every mathematician should be
required to spend some time in jail so
they can be as productive yeah so take
that as as advice that's career advice
but not seriously okay so what did he do
well basically he came up with a pairing
what is a pairing a pairing is something
that takes two points on the curve and
maps them somewhere else and this
pairing has this amazing property that
if you apply them to you know P times an
integer and Q times an integer the
integers tend to multiply so in effect
what this does is kind of gives us a
one-time CDH algorithm but not really
what it does is it does a one-time CDH
but it moves us to some other structure
moves us we're not left on the curve
anymore we kind of moved somewhere else
okay so allows us to do one computation
one product of these us and vs but as a
result we have to move somewhere else
turns out this pairing is efficiently
computable this was due to victor miller
and that actually this tool was an
enormous gift to crypto it's extremely
extremely effective i was going to show
you one application but i think I'll
skip it and I'll just tell you that
there are enormous number of
applications to this tool again you're
going to have the slide so you can look
at the set of applications it's at this
point there are literally thousands of
papers written on using this tool so
very very productive use of pairings and
so just to conclude my talk I'd like to
say that I'd like to kind of just survey
a little bit of what's happening in
crypto these days it's again an enormous
lis active field it's a very very good
time to be working in crypto lots and
lots of open problems lots of progress
on problems that have been open for many
years and so as I said one problem that
is actively being worked on is debate is
basically how do we choose curves how do
we choose a curve such that we're all
comfortable in that the problem the CDH
problem is hard on the curve another
amazing development that's happened in
recent years due to Garg gentry and
Halevi san jem Gorga's right here you
can say hi san john really has moved the
field forward is going beyond pairings
beyond pairing base crypto going to
something called multi linear maps if
you remember I told you that pairing
based crypto gives you one time CDH
molted in your Maps in some sense give
you a que time CDA to not only do you do
it once you can do the CD you can solve
the CDH problem K times and exactly K
times this was a major open problem for
many years and garde gentry and Halevi
were actually the first to give a tactic
solution to this problem really really
quite remarkable work that turned out to
have enormous applications in crypto the
most surprising application one that
took me about complete surprise is
something called code obfuscation which
is basically hide how to hide secrets
and software so I have a secret key that
I want to hide in software I can give
you the software and you'll never be
able to extract the key from the code
it's quite remarkable that this is
possible
and again it all Beit is based on these
multi linear maps so you can kind of see
the progression of ideas from curves to
pairing on curves to multilinear maps
which then later on give this wonderful
wonderful way of hiding he's in software
now I should say don't go and you know
start your startup on this idea right
away this is still you know in the early
stages of being developed but things
only improve over time so I would
imagine that over time we're actually
going to have much much more practical
and and secure ways of doing this and
finally I'll tell you the third area
that's very active in the world of
crypto is basically defense against
quantum computers so in my mind this is
an imminent attack on everything that we
have in crypto quantum cryptography of
course is something that's being heavily
worked on at berkeley the physics is
sound basically building a quantum
Krypton computing is something that's
heavily worked on here the physics is
sound we just have an engineering
problem for building these things
engineering problems tend to be solved
to get solved over time so I would
expect at some point to see quantum
computers quantum computers pretty much
destroy all the crypto that's deployed
out there today yes
so if they're developed tomorrow we have
a problem yes and so now is the time for
the crypto community to start developing
defenses against these quantum computers
and there's actually quite a bit of work
in building quantum resistance crypto so
that even if you have a quantum computer
the crypto system remains secure so even
if I friend Nancy develops a quantum
computer the crypto will still be secure
deploying it is a different matter but
at least we're working on on those kind
of solutions ok so if you want to get
involved in the world of crypto I'll
mention that there's a fun conference
called real world crypto that were
running in January January 2016
just if you search for real world crypto
you'll find it very quickly if you want
to learn more about crypto I'll just
very briefly mention there's a public
online course that I run called it's
called a MOOC I wrote down the URL for
that it's free everybody's welcome to
sign up and there's a lot of a lot more
detail than what I was able to do
day so thank you very much I was really
happy to come and give this talk and I
will stop here